in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Dexter
and Cristina are with us hey guys how
are you hi hey welcome here better than
I deserve where you guys from Louisville
Kentucky oh just up the road that's not
too bad a drive to Nashville yeah but
with the kids was kind of long yeah well
yeah I think there's a multiple effect
that's like what is normally a
three-hour drive is like a 17 hour drive
and you got little kids but yeah very
cool welcome guys so you're here to do
your debt-free scream yes sir very cool
how much have you paid off two hundred
and sixty five thousand dollars oh just
like that and how long did that take 45
months Wow and a range of income during
that time household income started about
ninety and ended at about a hundred and
twenty last year yeah whoa what kind of
debt was the two hundred sixty five
thousand dollars alone school loan yen
yeah I had a house from a previous
marriage and I hated that house and it's
gone now okay so you sold a house hold
it how much did the house bring uh two
hundred okay and then the rest of
sixty-five thousand you just plowed
through yep yes there got artwork very
cool so big school loans now you got
t-shirts on for those listening on the
radio you need to look deeply into your
radio you see that Texas is really big
and bold it says not a victim and
Christina says uh I'm debt free and
loving it right yes very cool so what's
not a victim mean uh dave in this day
and age man everybody's got an excuse
for everything you want to blame
everybody else for the problems you know
your life's not going to change until
you start taking responsibility for
yourself and start seeing yourself as a
hero and you know you can wait on a
politician all day you can wait on
anybody gonna be waiting forever you got
to take charge of your life decide
you're not going to be a victim you got
to go out there and win people are gonna
tell you you can't do something you
can't do this you know you know your
oppress don't listen to that mess Wow
so you can fill in for me when I'm gone
no hey you got you got this down man
that's well what you what do you do for
a living I'm a police officer say oh wow
very cool in Louisville yes sir
what do you do Christina I'm a program
manager okay Wow very cool very cool so
I you decided that it was your problem
and you needed to fix it that's what
you're saying yeah okay
so what happened 45 months ago that
started this journey on this Dave Ramsey
craziness well she told me she was
pregnant I did not believe it oh you put
your hands over the years I wasn't ready
in my mind I'm no Iraq war veteran it
just in my mind I was just thinking I'm
not ready to be a father
and she's like usually with you find out
that pregnant glorious I was stressed
out the press the entire nine months
because my mind I'm thinking financially
we're not ready to have a kid yet and
that just kicked me into overdrive whoa
we got oh we went through FPU together a
lot of class and see I mean she's been
my rock the whole time without working
cool very cool so Christina did you see
that switch flip in his brain when he
got like real game on yeah I did I'm
gonna be a daddy game on game oh it was
all right wasn't to the end I liked it
that's very cool very cool so what what
was the most important thing once you
had that baby wake-up call and that by
the way is the best wake-up call for
people it looks like suddenly you go
into grown-up mode I mean you go into I
got a deal people do it I did I remember
that same feeling that I was like oh
this got real how did that happen that's
a different show so uh I mean what what
um other than I mean once that you got
that call what was the most important
thing that you think you guys learned
about handling money that caused you to
be able to do this Herculean feat I mean
you knocked out a bunch of dad just know
we more than anything we gave it to God
and we prayed together honey and we
learn to dream together and have a
together mmm I mean we talk about
everything you know a lot of my friends
I've know people get married like well
no mother this is my bank account her
bank account
no we're one we're gonna share
everything no secrets
no no suit your money I mean we got
focused and did it together yeah cool
Cristina and I would say from for me is
definitely paying our tithes mm-hmm and
our pies praying from the beginning and
continual not stop it so and then pin
our ties you know when you give God
gives back to you so things that we
needed God had already blessed us with
mm-hmm yeah your the trust is there
that's what changes with that I think
tithe there's a part of time that means
trust and it's like who is in control
okay I'm going to admit I'm not and
that's that's really what the tithe says
and that there's something breaks loose
when you do that and it is a spiritual
journey and I'm often sometimes a
detractor somebody that doesn't like
what we do I can't believe you to make
spirituality with with money and I'm
always like I can't believe you don't
it's like it's like the most spiritual
thing in the world I mean because it
flows to everything that matters and so
you're able to help you're able to give
you're able to bless that's what we want
to do about you're able to take care of
your own household I mean all these
things are very scriptural so very fun
well congratulations you guys okay so
yet some young couples listening out
there they just got the news that the
babies on the way and they had an oh god
moment Oh God and uh what do you tell
them the secret is to getting out of
that I'm gonna tell them hard work I
mean David I've probably wasn't talking
in some weeks 100 120 hours whoa I was
going I would literally I would come in
from work I would lay down for hour and
a half I would get up and I go over put
on my uniform go right back out the door
Wow I was determined Wow fell intensity
was real yeah so that's that's you
knowing you're not a victim I'm going to
take control it's not somebody else's
fault work we're cleaning this mess with
the Bible verse I said let no rest come
to your eyes no secret to success is not
a straight road that's death that's for
sure amen
Christina what do you say the secret is
you said the time I got yet part
definitely and I see as a wife just be
supportive you know and if it's the kids
take care of the kids but also
definitely be supportive of your husband
because obviously he's working like a
maniac
yes yeah Wow you guys are awesome
I'm honored to meet you I'm so proud of
you you are the hero of your story yeah
and you went and did it you are I love
the t-shirts I love the mindset of where
you are and I've got a feeling being a
policeman is an absolute ministry for
you I love it I love I feel like I'm
walking my blessings every day I put
them on uniform and I go to work I'm
like where God wants me and needs me
amen amen you're doing good stuff there
man
very very cool stuff and he brought me a
really cool Louisville police patch and
t-shirt so I'm set up now man thank
thank you thanks to appreciate thank you
sir so the baby's names are Brooklyn and
Brooklyn is how old she is three years
old huh
and mr. DJ mr. DJ has stole the show
around here he is six eight nine yeah
everybody comes by and sees mr. DJ
they've got their own t-shirts and their
t-shirts one of their t-shirts say DJ's
is cash is king baby and Brooklyn says I
screamed I'm dead free day's day which
is getting ready to do yes as Brooklyn
been practicing her debt-free scream yes
he has so she's got it down she's been
in it mr. DJ mr. J DJ's getting ready
get a shock cause the volume on this
gonna be big all right so two hundred
and sixty five thousand dollars paid off
oh we're gonna give you a copy of Chris
Hogan's book retire inspired because
that's the name next chapter in your
hero story so you're going to go be
millionaires and be a blessing to your
family and to others you get very good
stuff so $265,000 paid off that includes
the sale of a house for two hundred
thousand forty five months making 90 to
120 and two babies during the time this
is how it's done
Dexter and Christina Brooklyn and DJ
count it down let's hear a debt free
screaming three two one when
I love it well done you two
well done well done well done very proud
of you man that is awesome that's how
it's done you know I'm uh I'm always
impressed with somebody that decides
that no matter what the situation I'm
not a victim I'm the hero and when you
decide that you change your life I don't
care how old you are on your man or
woman what part of the country you grew
up on how much it how much education
you've got whether you're black white
asian Hispanic I don't care I don't care
we've all got our deal it's up to you do
you you can do this stuff it's awesome
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you can
do this you know that really is a
message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income or a five
hundred thousand dollar income
you